the focus is
on adam wainwright making his 317th
career start he loves pitching this
place career era
in st louis is a full run lower than on
the road 302 to newman
chopped over to wong gold glover retires
newman
here's brian reynolds this one in the
left
o'neal goes back caught at the warning
track there's two away
here's fraser the number three hole
hitter the curveball lifted into right
there's dexter fowler welcome back wayno
welcome back baseball fans wherever you
may be
now the cardinals will come up against
right-hander trevor williams
got off to a good start last year but
you know had some struggles
now paul goldschmidt just tore up the
pirates since he's come to st
louis he's 28 for 66 against the pirates
that's at 4
24 average goldschmidt with a drive
out to deep left it's at the wall
goodbye off of big maclan
a prodigious blast
oh my goldsmith makes it one-nothing
cardinals back-to-back base hits and
pittsburgh has something going on both
of those hits
on curveballs up in the zone doesn't
have right now the vertical drop early
in the game that he normally has
i think it hit him definitely came up
and in and yes it did
so that loads the bases in the top of
the second for the pittsburgh pirates
now john ryan murphy the catcher
when joss misses on the top of the zone
just misses
the bases loaded walk scores josh bell
and ties the game
and now number two not out of the woods
yet
mr wayne right hey you'll you know
you're in for a battle with newman
reaches out and pokes it to short the
young charges throws nice pick at first
by goldschmidt
wayne right in the cardinals get out of
the inning but the pirates do tie it
o'neal moves to third vader on the
second but now two outs
but two in scoring position for paul
goldsmith a swing and a lighter
caught at third evans secures the final
out and the inning is over so the first
two reach
they're left on runners at the corner
for dexter fowler
and a home run to kick off his 20-20 on
friday evening
there's a base set in the center field
dexter fowler scores paul deyoung
and st louis reclaims the lead tyler
o'neal first and second form
gets good wood on it into left field
yadi is on second
given the ghost sign throw to third not
in time
molina scores now 3-1 st louis i can
empathize man
it's i i want to know where he was last
night
somewhere somewhere it's having a good
time park village
oh yeah day games after night games oh
man that adam wainwright's back out to
work here in the sixth inning
working with a 3-1 lead josh bell could
not hold up there
so wainwright punches his ticket wayne
right up to 80 pitches
moran pulls it to paul goldschmidt will
do it himself
wayne right he's settled down goes
upstairs does crick
and beats tommy edmond but he's not out
of the inning not by a long shot here
comes paul goldschmidt
only one for three first pitch right
back to crick he lost the baseball
goldschmidt is safe the bases are loaded
to paul the young
the young with a base hit into left
field
vader scores one hustling around third
and the cardinals lead five to one over
the buccos
now carpenter the left-handed hitter
matt carpenter
into right center field off the base of
the wall tucker can't grab it
the throw comes in as do two more runs
seven to one cardinals we have two outs
in the cardinals eighth inning a seven
to one game and the cardinals are
looking
for more of a two outs tommy edmond is
over four today
that's lifted in the air out to deep
left field it's at the wall
and it's off the wall tommy edmond
already at second
one run in here comes another edmond to
third with a triple
in a blink of an eye he drives in two to
make it nine to one
tommy edmund with his triple tyler webb
is the new pitcher the lefty for the
cardinals josh bell is one out of three
this afternoon
you may see webb get a couple outs here
not sure
that's backhanded by the young but this
would be the opportune time
might be ponce de leon as well just to
get a little extra work
fly ball into right lane thomas is there
ricardo's are one out away from going a
2-0
mike shield will indeed go to his
bullpen and get a little work
it'll be daniel ponce de leon daniel
ponce de leon trying to pick
up the final out here with two outs in
the top of the ninth
line to third it is caught by tommy
edmond
and with that the cardinals are 2-0
and adam wainwright is third all-time
in wins in cardinals history he is tied
with
bob force a historic win for adam
wainwright